the cowboys ravens game had another
wrinkle that we were fascinated by i
know i was dez bryant cut by the cowboys
abruptly in april of 2018 after all the
money had been spent in free agency
which made it harder for him to find a
new home he eventually did with the
saints toward achilles tendon in his
first practice sat out all of 2019
landed on the ravens practice squad and
i still believe the flirtation with dez
bryant was an effort to placate
guys in the locker room that wanted
antonio brown but des worked hard he
worked out he got to the active roster
being called up then he made it the
active roster permanently at least as
permanent as it ever is in the nfl and
anticipating he was we were everyone was
dez bryant on the field against the team
that drafted him 10 years ago and he was
on the field getting ready for the game
when he found out
he won't be playing in the game
because of a positive covet 19 test and
here's what happened and this is one of
the
strange
i don't want to say inequities
of the process but it kind of is
the closer you are
to one of the five bioreference
laboratories the quicker you get your
results
for the daily pcr testing
and the ravens are close to a laboratory
one of the five labs is in maryland so
the sooner that the samples physically
arrive at the lab
the sooner they get tested the sooner
you get the results and all year long
the ravens have been routinely getting
their results in that 5 to 6 p.m eastern
time window
every day
i think they get tested a little bit
later for a night game right right game
day night game you get tested a little
bit later but the results came in right
around 7 eastern for dez bryant the
off-site pcr test by bioreference
laboratory showed inconclusive so test
them again and
the nfl has shifted and this has been
fairly quiet in large part because most
of the fans don't care but what's
happened is they've gone from the
on-site point-of-care
test the low accuracy test that looks
for the antigens not the actual virus
they've moved from that to a system
created by mesa which is essentially not
essentially it is an on-site pcr test
that looks for the actual virus and it's
pretty accurate so they gave des bryant
the on-site mesa pcr test and it was
positive
and that was that he's yanked from the
game this is the closest the nfl has
come to what happened in the world
series game where the dodgers player got
yanked during the game right and the nfl
has said they would do it during the
game this is before the game just before
the game they find out dez bryant's
positive he's off the field he's not
happy he had a tweet storm last night
which at times was a little bit
emotional as it would be i can't blame
him cowboys he gets pulled off the field
i just said the same thing i'm done i'm
quitting i'm never playing again
and
and and look i i think that he'll
eventually realize that the smart move
is to keep playing but he was unhappy
and i can understand why he was unhappy
because you're locked in you're ready to
go as far as you know you're playing
football you're not even aware that
something like this can happen and it
happens and it happens to you in what
you think is the biggest game
of the year so he ultimately said yes
he's coming back he's being smart so he
just had to work out that that initial
emotional frustration yeah i don't blame
him no i mean gosh man the guy has been
through everything
i mean been through everything first off
he hasn't had like the easiest life in
the world yeah he played in the nfl did
all did some great things we know that
has the injury you know
dallas lets him go
okay as close to coming back with the
new orleans saints has in the another
injury that hurts him there you know and
then he's sitting out of football
waiting for his chance he finally gets
his chance he's just getting back into
like kind of playing shape playing form
and oh man the team that drafted me and
let me go in the city that i still live
in they're coming to town the dallas
cowboys and it's a big game for us and
they stink and maybe i have a chance to
go off and you know shove it where the
sun don't shine for as far as that
they're concerned i mean that that's
just the heartbreaker and then to be
teased it's one thing to like get hurt
during the week or you know pull a hammy
on a friday but you're like get it's
game day now and you're all you're
taught thinking about his game and now
you're gonna go on the field and warm up
like as a player i mean that you're
you're in a total different mindset
you're foaming at the mouth you can't
wait and i can't even imagine how much
he couldn't wait for for this type of
scenario so
i feel for him and i understand that
onslaught of tweets and everything like
that but he did drink some wine and he
coped and he's gonna be back so i'm
happy about that
all we have from dez are the tweets
we've got some sound from both john
harbaugh the coach the ravens and dez
bryant's teammate derek wolfe on what
happened with dez here they are
well that's a big challenge you know i
mean the timing of this thing is it's a
crazy kind of a deal but we'd already
turned in our inactives
and uh and then we were informed eric
came down and told me that um
dez had a um
an inconclusive test and they were
retesting one of the one of the quick
tests they have the mesa test
and we had to wait on that and in the
meantime the late told us we would not
be allowed to bring a different player
up
if he if he tested positive but if he
tested positive that he wasn't going to
be allowed to play
my understanding that they did all the
contact tracing all the procedures were
followed as far as any other player
is concerned
but then they came back out while we
were on the field in pre-game warm-ups
and said that uh he had tested positive
and so he would not be allowed to play
and that's where we were at so we played
with a man short on that one we didn't
find out until like i was in full pads
taped up eye black on ready to go
you know and then when they came into
the locker room like hey dez can't go
and then we were like well no the nfl
made us play a guy short the league made
us play a guy short so
they wouldn't let us bring another guy
up which is
yeah to me i think we maybe need to look
at that role and maybe change it but
that's the rule so we got to play by the
rules but you know with covet i think we
have to have some leeway to change that
you know
yeah both guys are referring to the rule
this year that allows teams to bring up
to 16 players from the practice squad to
the active roster on game day but after
the inactives are turned in 90 minutes
before kickoff that's it the rosters are
locked but like does need to be there's
there's going to be something
yeah well maybe there should be because
you know we we knew because the nfl said
in the aftermath of that dodgers game
they would pull a guy off a field during
a game if they found out he tested
positive
we hadn't thought about maybe they
hadn't thought about the possibility of
getting a positive during that window
from 90 minutes before kickoff and
kickoff where you could
tell a replacement from the practice
squad
get in your uniform get ready you're
playing right so that is something that
i think they should consider even if it
is just for the final four weeks of the
regular season because that does
eliminate some of the unfairness now
there's a lot of skepticism and dez is
one of the ones who raised this question
himself how is it that you can play the
game if i've tested positive because
what this means is
he showed up for work shedding virus he
was in the locker room
shedding virus he was out on the field
before the game
shedding
virus and the nfl
and initially i saw some reports citing
sources sources sources i asked the nfl
you know can you explain to me what
happened they gave me a statement on the
record here's what happened we did the
contact tracing the system worked the
protocols worked we talked to the right
people we checked the contact tracing
device and you know maybe it's a
testament to the ravens learning the
hard way yeah from their outbreak to
keep a part in the locker room right and
it helps when it's a home game we've
talked in the past about how the
visiting team locker room can be a
little bit cramped and give us a fairly
graphic example of someone's butt in
your face yes but the home team locker
room you can you can spread out and it
sounds like they were smart about it the
one glitch in all this though chris and
there was a photo posted by
ryan mink i believe his name is who
works for the ravens digital operation
of dez bryant out on the field hugging
people before the game
and you know the nfl's reaction to this
is
it's still not enough and obviously that
tweet was deleted once it became clear
that there were questions about
dez bryant possibly spreading virus
before the game but remember that quick
interaction is not a concern
it has to be a sustained contact the
viral load that gets passed from one
person to the next this isn't just that
one and i don't understand it i'm not
enough i know i don't know
those who do but it isn't just that one
microscopic molecule that's floating
through the air it takes enough that it
gets into your body it takes root and
then the process of multiplication
begins and that's one of the things
they've learned in the eight months
we've been dealing with this so the
nfl's position is yeah it's no big deal
if he was hugging people out on the
field before the game
the reality is you've got to be in
closer contact for a sustained period of
time to be at risk of catching it now
we'll see we'll see we'll test that
theory we'll find out if anyone from the
cowboys that he may have been hugging
last night pops with a negative or
positive or if any of the the ravens
teammates do and they end up with a new
outbreak that would be awful if that
happened but uh you know it's it's not
it's not quite as clear or quite as easy
because you just don't know you have to
wait and see but the nfl is confident
that the protocols worked and they they
got to where they needed to be even
though no one else was shut down and the
game was allowed to proceed yeah i mean
it does seem like it's a loophole a
little bit i mean certainly but we have
enough evidence of guys being on the
field with that are positive
and other guys on the football field
don't get it i mean we we do have that
so that doesn't mean oh yeah just
because he hugged a guy i mean i still
that picture of stefan gilmore face to
face
face to face with patrick mahomes right
after that game will always stand up in
my mind to just like okay outside yep
and then all the things you're talking
about that you know sustained
transmission and everything there too
the other thing that i think probably
you know saved the baltimore ravens and
saved the game in general too
is
you know you look at the pregame
pictures and everything it looks like
dez was there very early like he's one
of the only players on the field in
almost every pre-game shot i saw so i
bet you he was one of the first people
in the locker room i bet you there
wasn't a lot of guys there yet too i bet
you that saved them a little as far as
the contact tracing and him not around
people because
most times nfl football game you got an
eight o'clock game
i would say
everybody's in the locker room by around
six o'clock right somewhere everybody's
in there but a lot of the love football
guys want to be there do everything like
that they they might get there at 4 30 5
o'clock maybe even earlier than that and
it looked like he was there
significantly early and maybe that
helped out the situation as far as
people being around him
dez was probably there as early as he
could possibly right because he had a
lot of passion he wanted yeah
boys he wanted the cowboys to see here i
am i'm still around let's hear quickly
from lamar jackson on dez being pulled
and and how the team reacted to that
development
well we found out we was on the field
you know warming up
and we only had like four receivers out
there you know we was looking around for
them then they told us
it was like we just had to pull the game
for him you know we got to win that game
for him because we know how much it
meant to him you know he's been talking
about it uh for a minute now since he's
been here so
that's just it's oh no i don't like you
know what happened but it is what it is
we got the vic reform um i'm feeling for
him though because i know he's you know
he it's a game he wanted to be in
he still provided the emotional lift and
that's what i was intrigued by how much
of a of a boost he would give the raven
not that they needed a lot of incentive
to avoid falling to six and six yeah but
it was a little extra it was a little
something and that was a disappointment
it was so weird how it was all unfolding
because we find out dez isn't going to
play and then there was a feature on the
fox pregame show about dez after we
found out he wasn't going to play and i
look i can't fault people you've got
everything locked and loaded you're
ready to go play the show but uh it just
it just was a strange
half hour to 45 minutes to get the game
started and that may be one of the
reasons why the ravens seemed a little
off early on you're a weird curveball
that gets thrown at your head right
before the game starts yeah i mean you
you you could be exactly right about
that yeah you get that type of news
throughout the team everybody's talking
about it everybody takes a step back oh
man that i feel bad for dez i can't
believe that you know who knows yeah
you're also thinking damn was i around
him what else was he around today uh
could all be a part of it but either way
at least baltimore got back back on the
right track
and they've just they've you know
weathered this storm of covid 19 and all
the issues they've had to deal with one
and one here now they're going to have
somewhat of a normal week going forward
and like you have said many times i
think they're getting close to being a
healthier football team that they were
you know five six
five six weeks ago and i they they could
go on a run here and be dangerous and
it's just going to be interesting to see
if they could pull this off and get hot
again and go into the playoffs and scare
some teams in the afc
the best news of all 13 weeks completed
every game that was scheduled has been
played yes it has taken some shifting to
get them all played but 13 weeks 13
weeks of games played the nfl has to be
feeling pretty good about that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports